nous combattons nos femmes
même s'ils ont besoin de manger
le fond 1 sur place ils résistent je
suis absolument persuadé que nous allons
résister nous défendons notre part
patrie notre pays est exceptionnel notre
peuple est remarquable
je tire veut
que ce peuple résiste que ce peuple leur
vie mais reste dans l'histoire en prime
mais en tant que peuple vivant
je veux garder notre état nous sommes
très jeunes eux sont prêts à tout et
bien évidemment ne sont prêts à entendre
vos questions
le président merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous et bbc news deux questions se
posent
vous avez un petit peu ralenti l'avancée
qu'il des envahisseurs mais nous voyons
des percées et des avancées qu'en pensez
vous combien de temps
tout cela encore prendre et quelles sont
les lignes rouges quelles sont les
conditions qui sont acceptables à votre
avis est-ce que c'est la délocalisation
à à l'est dans le sud quels sont vos
lignes rouges
je pense que tous ceux qui sont présents
ici ne peut pas élire jeu l'avenir à
qui l'armée russe
et je peux plus grandes
et les plus grandes de recettes non pas
de deux fois ni de trois fois plus court
la quantité les combattants dépasse de
près de 10 fois
les
combattants et qui tombe ne sont pas
contents ne sont pas comptabilisés que
ma tournée je sais qu'ils sont venus
chez nous avec un
matériau
dont ils sont bien anticipé le fait
qu'il n'avait aucune l'intention de
montrer toute sa vie au maire que leur
fiche
il me moreau bromont
tandis que nous défendons
nous voulons pas les tuer bellouti fois
après les autres que nous sort s'acharne
et j elle est très lent prisonniers
lorsque la douleur évitera tout autour
d'elle milica des combattants du kenya
tout simplement parce que chez nous il
ya des docteurs des médecins ce sont des
escrocs images d'abord et après on est
militaire et à la saur tandis que
windsor comme on dit à juste en déduire
que le manager rennais soucis avec toi
les crimes a dit jean monnet c'est un
garçon ces gens venus chez nous ça
public rit matériaux m'imaginer rousset
je sais comment
cette personne a pu mesurer ses actes ce
sont des actes du génie
de voir après boutique originale
gouvernements amis en réseau local et 6
juillet qu'il est suivi quand j'étais
jeune à lakeshore l'argent du monde déjà
acquis
ce profil si nous ne mettons pas un
terme à ces réactions kenneth suite de
l'attaqué que le député njawe temps sur
ces questions et par canon niche mais
que la fiom lezak se bougent années déjà
un bouclier la route des jeunes la
récession est passée la joie qui se
déconnectent loin du peuple et ce sont
des rumeurs les êtres humains également
le problème c'est que maison ça va ils
ont vit avec la peur au ventre et de
nous devons descendre dans les rues pour
dénoncer sézanne ont fusionné le monstre
at-il vont écrire et j'ai pu trouver les
gens ne se trouvent pas dans la rue dans
les rues dwaik obama il disait
finalement la monusco
n'était pas de décor qu'il a protesté
autres contre les indices avaient
absolument normal on ne voudrait avoir
en sarre on ne veut pas avoir à monaco
s'ils sont dans une démocratie
nietzsche rêve ce n'est pas un bout de
tours cyril temin je suis déjà mais il
doit avoir allaité d'enseigner en lead
en dirigeant devrait être capable de
tout faire pour que l'entreprise
voici que cette entreprise puisse être
connue et bienvenue dans le monde entier
c'est ça la
chef d'état il mange rien n'est caché il
s'était personnellement je ne suis pas
le meilleur combattant ce que les autres
peut-être que je tire est bien c'est que
le délai aujourd'hui je ne suis pas voir
le gardien de la constitution je suis
devenu luganais qui est un peu ma nation
je pouvais j'aurais effectivement et
perverse plus
j'ai mobilisé si j'étais par exemple si
je ne faisais pas partie du ministère de
la défense où des combattants j'aurais
fait plus cher en termes un peu cela
mais si jamais sûr j'étais en syldavie
on m'avait donné un ordre de tuer son
nom je leur ai parlé à nos abonnés
regardez bien
récupérer en rien au regard
des garçons qui sont des garçons dix
huit cent vingt ans j'ai fait dans 40 50
ma fille a le même âge que ses soldats
s'étaient habitués 8 eb je imagine
l'émoi chez les garçons dit
être très bien mais aucun n'est prêt
choix ou bien ce sont des gens me monter
le zonage et filles ont décidé de
l'inviter revenir
et d'envahir mot n'est pas un bien
regarder ces garçons sont ils arrivés au
combat y abonner rotich vnf prématuré et
je rêve
les gars ont brûlé dans les bras parce
que c'est pas né en août non c'est pas
pour
d'autres c'est mon dieu qui broie de
préjugés
d'accueillir en irlande